[Music]
okay let's go ahead and open up the
doors do the daily with Doc and Becca
and today is our Friday one of my
favorite days of the week with
pharmacist Friday and the one and only
pharmacist Ben fuches now folks if you
have never heard pharmacist Ben fuches
you are in for a treat as he is bringing
from the medical side of it and
incorporating it into the nutritional
side of it and then topping it off with
going into science and how everything
Works which for those of us who are kind
of geeky I think it's perfect for those
that are not that's okay because the way
he explains it it makes it
understandable so folks get ready for an
amazing show on daily withd and Becca
now this program is being sponsored by
daily withth
do.com so if you have never visited our
website and you are not part of our
email a list make sure that you do so
this is um the website itself is for
those who have never spoken to anybody
about youngevity or have never tried the
products um outside of the critical
Health news or daily with Doc family of
um youngevity Distributors but if you
were referred to somebody you make sure
that you get back with them and tell
them what you liked best about the
program and ask them if they can assist
you in figuring out what it is that you
need to maintain your health or choose a
different Health Journey if you're going
down a road that you don't particularly
care for so that is one nice thing about
the way the body was designed is that
when we give it the right ingredients
the body itself can do some amazing
things now products don't diagnose cure
or treat anything but folks God didn't
make junk so
it can do a lot of stuff on its own now
pharmacist
Ben he started out in the pharmacy Arena
going to school learning about all the
different things that they teach you in
pharmacy school but one thing that's
different between pharmacy school and
medical school itself training you as a
doctor is they go more into the
nutrition side of it and I love the fact
that he found so much value in the
nutrition side of it that he was
recommending nutrition with the
Pharmaceuticals that were being
recommended at the pharmacy or by the
doctor then they take them to the
pharmacy but then he was also saying
well why don't you try this instead and
they they fired him can you believe that
you give somebody something that their
body can actually use for its benefit
not just Mass symptoms and you get fired
well that didn't stop him so I'm super
excited to be able to bring to the
screen with me pharmacist Ben fukes who
has been doing this for a few decades
and has dug super deep
into this pharmaceutical side the
medical side the scientific side and how
everything works into in the body and
Ben thank you so so much for bringing
this Friday to us I know we're going to
be talking about the electrical system
with
this well we're g to talk about how
healing and health and disease is really
electrical even though we talk about
it um just lost you here even though we
talk about it from a from a chemical
point of view chemistry only works
because of electricity when we're sick
we talk about being sick chemically in
terms of drugs and in terms of nutrition
um um and we re we use chemical
modalities to help put the body back
into uh into to help readjust the body
back to a healthy state but really at
the end of the day it's all about
electricity chemistry is just the
physical manifestation of electricity of
electrons can't really see electricity
um you can't really but you can see the
results of electricity and chemistry is
one of the results of electricity a
chemical is made up a bunch of molecules
the molecules made of bunch of atoms and
an atom is just really an electrical
substance
so basically we're not chemical we're
electrical and a chemical only works as
well as uh as well as uh its electrical
nature and the body's electrical
response to the electrical stimulus of
that chemical so you know for just to
give you a simple
example um many of you guys probably
heard of receptors and things that sit
into receptors and I can't see anybody
so I'm going to just use you Rebecca as
my as my totem for everybody you have a
cell and you have a receptor and then
things sit in the receptor and things
happen right that you've seen that kind
of you've heard that imagery before you
have a receptor things sit in the
receptor cells action happens that's how
actions happen we always say all disease
is cell disease but how is it that a
cell functions well functions via
interactions between things from the
outside and things that sit on the
receptors I like to think of receptors
as
ears and chemicals that sit in the
receptors as words so I'm talking to you
now the words go into your ears and you
have a response cell does the same thing
we call these receptors almost like a
plug in a socket you can think a
receptor like a socket if not like an
ear like a socket and then a chemical
sits in that socket like a plug and then
a reaction happens but here's the thing
when we think of a plug's k going into a
socket we think of actually the plug
touching the socket but the plug plug
doesn't really touch the socket the the
thing that sits in the receptor isn't
really touching the receptor it's
magnetic rically changing it and by the
way Electro electricity and magnetism
for our purposes here we going we're
going to use them
synonymously it's called
electromagnetism because magnetism is
one side of the coin and electricity is
the other side of the coin so they're
essentially the same coin what it's just
viewed at from a different perspective
so things sit into the cell receptor via
magnetism and electricity why is this
important because if the shape of that
receptor is distorted or change the
electrical action is not going to happen
correctly and the cell's not going to be
healthy the cell's not going to be able
to respond to that um to that
interaction that the the plug hitting
the socket that's one place where
electricity plays a very important role
is in the interaction between the thing
that sits into the receptor by the way
the thing that sits into the receptor we
call that a Lian that's just a a fancy
biochemical term the Lian is anything
that sits in the receptor for the most
part it's hormones or peptides te call
them liand so we'll just use that term
for the plug a liand is a plug a
receptor is a socket the liand plug sits
in the receptor socket and chemistry
happens that's how everything happens in
a Cell uh in response to the outside
world this is how cells respond to the
outside world now for a cell the cell
doesn't see the sun and it doesn't see
you know my computer and it doesn't see
the table all a cell sees is the fluid
it's sitting in
so a cell is sitting in fluid a soup and
that soup is the major determining
factor for how that cell is going to
reside or respond cell sits in the soup
for our for our conversation today the
soup we'll call the blood it's not
exactly right because the soup is
derived from the blood but for our
purposes here today will call the soup
the blood so if there's any biochemists
out there don't hold my feet to the fire
on this because I'm simplifying okay so
the soup the cell sits in the soup for
our purposes here today the soup is the
blood that's why I always say all
disease is cell disease but all cell
disease is preceded by Dirty blood so
when the cell is sitting in this soup
and that soup is dirty it's not going to
be able to communicate with the liand as
effectively this is why we got to keep
the soup clean almost all the things we
do as a culture are designed to dirty
the soup to muck up the soup and this is
where disease starts that's why all
disease is cell disease but all dis cell
diseases preceded by Dirty blood so the
soup becomes dirty and one way you can
look at this is by a phenomena called
doping you know you ever see those
commercials why do you think they call
it dope remember that when we were kids
why do you think they call it dope you
ever wonder why they call marijuana or
drugs they call them Dope what where
that word come from why they call people
a dopes that they're stupid what is a
dope well yes so I was always told they
don't call it or told they don't call it
dope because it makes you smart right
why do they why do we why do we uh refer
to dope as something that makes you
stupid well how did the word dope come
about numbs your senses where does the
word dope come from it's a It's actually
an Electronics word when you have when
you're making a
semiconductor they dope the
semiconductor to create changes in how
it conducts electricity usually they
dope semiconductors to make it conduct
electricity a little more efficiently
what doping is doping is actually an
electronic
word it's a word that comes does that
have anything to do with dopamine no
dopamine is a completely different thing
okay so dopamine is dopa and that's a
that's a a chemical abbreviation but
that's something different so dope to
dope something is to pollute
it when you dope something you pollute
it uh there's a phenomena in um uh in
bicycle racing I don't know if you know
anything about bicycle racing but a lot
of bicycle Racers to get super extra
power they will dope their blood it's
called blood doping and blood doping is
actually an illegal thing because by
sticking dope in the blood they get
extra energy blood doping they use
various chemicals to make the blood more
efficient so they can be more effective
athletes but that's illegal that's
cheating I don't know if you remember
Lance Armstrong got got in trouble for
this right for blood doping so blood
doping is an example of how you can dop
dope things to create changes when we
dope the blood or when we eat sugar or
we take drugs or we have uh excess
wastes from inflammation we're doping
the blood the blood becomes doped the
blood becomes stupid it becomes polluted
and this changes the way it interacts
with cells this is one place where the
electrical nature of the fluids that the
cell is sitting in can uh have an impact
on health and wellness and disease
another example of electricity in the
body involves the movement of blood as
fluids move through uh as special fluids
move blood uh in our example that we're
using now as blood moves it's generating
electrical charges the way it generates
electrical charges is very
interesting the blood is not just fluid
it's not just water the blood has pieces
in it lots of stuff inside the blood and
the stuff inside the blood in
combination with the movement generates
electrical
charges and the exact uh
proportion of stuff in the blood to
fluid and the exact composition of stuff
in the blood is critical for the
generation of electrical charges by the
way the generation of electrical charges
is called a Zeta potential I don't know
if you ever heard that term Zeta
potential The Zeta potential is the
electrical charge that's generated in
the blood as it's circulating through
the body the gener uh the generation of
that Zeta potential is extremely
important for the circulation however
once we start to dope the blood once we
start to contaminate the blood that
changes its
composition the change in the
composition of the blood results in a
change in the electrical energy so
you've got changes in the fluids that
the cell is sitting in you got changes
in the in the uh in the composition of
the blood both of which are going to
impact how well the how electrically
functioning the B how well the
electricity the bio electricity in the
body is going to function this is why
all disease is cell disease but all cell
diseases preceded by Dirty blood when we
talk about dirty blood we're talking
about an electrical phenomena we talk
about all disease being celf disease
we're talking about an elect elal
phenomena cancer cells just to give you
a classic example are cells that have a
distorted a distorted electrical nature
cancer cells have and all disease cells
have distorted electrical Natures so you
have the the uh electricity and the
stuff that's sitting around an
electrical nature to the fluids that the
cell is sitting in you have an
electrical nature to the blood that is
circulating through the body and then
you have the electrical nature of the
cell itself the cell itself is akin to a
little battery in fact not only is the
cell itself like a little battery but
the little structures inside the cell
are little batteries so you have
batteries within batteries within
batteries within batteries you have
electrical substances within electrical
substances within electrical substances
within electrical substan you have
nested electrical substances from the
blood to the fluid to the cells to the
uh uh to substructures within the cells
even the DNA itself is uh is an
electrical con uh conducting
system the most uh probably the most
important of the electrical substances
in the cell is the outside part of the
cell we call that a cell membrane in
fact one of the most important uh uh
developments or one of the most
important um pieces pieces of
electronics in a computer the chip is
based on a concept called
semi
conduction semi conduction is not
conduction it's semi conduction so what
is conduction conduction is the movement
of
electricity so what is
semiconduction semiconduction is
amazingly important phenomena we could
not have the world we live in if it
weren't for our our manufactured
semiconduction and body itself could not
exist as it is if it weren't for
biological
semiconduction so you know conduction is
movement like when electricity moves
it's being conducted right conduct means
to uh pull pull through by the way
education eduction is to pull out so
when you educate someone when you
educt what you're doing is you're
pulling things out which is very
interesting because when people think of
Education they think of the opposite so
if I'm educating you you may think that
I'm actually talking to you so I'm
putting things into you but that's not
what I'm doing I'm pulling things out of
you so eduction is actually to pull
things out of people conduction is the
same phenomena except for its movement
so what is a semiconductor a
semiconductor is when movement occurs SP
uh
sporadically
intermittently instead of moving going
this like this it goes like
this instead of straight it gets moved
intermittently and this is how computers
work you've probably heard of something
called binary uh the binary nature of
computers zeros and ones right yeah
zeros and ones are on and
off straight conduction is all on
semiconduction is on
off semiconduction is onof it's
conduction is just
one semiconduction is zero one and it's
the
semiconduction that allows a straight
electrical charge to become
information by controlling the amount of
on offs you can store information that's
how computer works now I don't I don't I
don't want to overwhelm people too much
because the point I'm making is this is
how cell membranes work and this is how
the
semiconduction uh the semiconductive
nature of the Body Works the whole body
the parts of the body and the cells
themselves don't conduct in uh don't
conduct electricity straight they
conduct electricity on
off so the whole body is now like a
computer via its semiconductive nature
in terms of the cell the semiconductor
the most important semiconductor is the
membrane
and this is what makes the membrane akin
to a computer chip computer chip is a
very very elaborate
semiconductor if you ever look at a
computer chip you'll see you probably
seen this image of all of these little
tiny wires these little tiny lines going
around those little tiny wires going
around conduct electrical charges in a
semiconduction fashion by going on and
off and this is how information is
stored so a cell membrane is like a
little computer chip
it's storing information by the way a
cell membrane is microscopically small
it's if you looked at in a microscope
all it would look like is a little film
like a little sliver of oil but really
it's a computer chip and you have a 100
trillion of these things so you have
your body is made up of a 100 trillion
independent computer chips via the cell
membrane so if you think the cell if you
if you previously knew that the cell
membrane was important now you know how
unbelievably important the cell membrane
is
the cell membrane the this little layer
on the outside part of a cell is like
the brain of a cell the nucleus is not
the brain of the cell a lot of times
people will think that the nucleus is
the brain of the cell because it has the
DNA in it and this is what the medical
model is kind of telling us is that the
intelligence of the cell is in the DNA
and this is why they want to manipulate
the DNA the DNA is not the intelligence
of the cell the DNA is the blueprint for
all of the things that are made in the
cell but it's not intelligent it's just
a blueprint it depends on the signals
that are coming from the computer chip
from the membrane the me brain is the
mem brain like the brain it is the
computer ship it is the intelligence of
the cell it's determining via
semiconduction what kind of messages are
going to come into the cell and
ultimately into the DNA now I told you
when I we started Rebecca that you know
I find this really fascinating there's
I'm only giving you a little taste of
all the electricity in the body but you
don't really need to know this if you
just want to heal yourself or you just
want to be in the healing business or
you just want to stay healthy but it's
important to recognize that our bodies
are
incredibly mind blowingly complex and
intricate and they're Mo they're uh
complex and intricate at the tiniest of
tiniest and tiniest of scales but it's
not really incred you don't really
necessarily have to know how the whole
thing works it's just amazing to think
about now another very important place
where uh electricity plays a role in the
body is in really something that is very
common that we think about all the time
but we don't really think of it as an
electrical substance and that is in its
water the water in the body is
electrically charged and the electrical
charges of the water in the body come
from various places one of the places
where the electrical charges in the uh
in the water come from
is the connective tissue you know I'm
always talking about the importance of
connective tissue one of the reasons why
the connective tissue there's a lot of
reasons but one of the reasons why the
connective tissue is so important is
because it's reacting with the
water to charge it to give it to give it
electricity and the combination of the
connected tissue specifically the
collagen and the fluid the water
organizes the water this is what's
called structured water you've often
heard that the body is made up of 60 to
70% water right that's not true it's
made up of 60 to
70% structured water which is a
completely different form of water it's
like a solid water if you can imagine a
solid water not ice it's a solid water
that's crystallin in fact it's said to
be a liquid Crystal you may have heard
the term liquid crystals in terms of
your monitor your computer monitor which
is a liquid Crystal a liquid Crystal is
a a a form of liquid that can change its
uh Tech its texture and its composition
can become more solid or become less
solid it can become more liquid or it
can become less liquid by
varying the electrical
charges when the electrical charges are
high the water becomes more structured
when it's lower the water becomes more
fluid as we
age one of the most distressing parts of
Aging I was looking a picture myself
recently today and I realized I don't
look the same as I did when I was 20 and
30 and what and nobody does and one of
the reasons is is because we start to
bloby we lose our structure this is a
very distressing part of aging and
people spend billions maybe trillions of
dollars as a a collectively to try to
restructure our body it can't do it
because in order to re people try to
inject things to restructure the body
and have surgical procedures and
tightening things done to the body and
there's all kinds of mechanical ways
that we can artificially attempt to
restructure the body but the body is
losing its structure because it's losing
its ability to to or organiz water it's
losing its ability to organize water
because the connective tissue is
deteriorating this is why the very
essence of anti-aging is building the
connective tissue when you have strong
connective tissue you have strong
electrical interactions with the with
the water and everything becomes more
solidified so building the connective
tissue is a very important part of
allowing the body to function allowing
the body to become more functional from
an electrical phenomen electrical
perspective the connective tissue itself
is
bioelectrical and uh ancient folks
ancient Health practitioners knew about
this they knew that by manipulating the
electronics of the connective tissue
they could make the body
healthier 5,000 years ago they knew this
what did they do to manipulate the
electronics of the connective tissue
they stuck needles in it and by sticking
needles in the connective tissue you
could change the way electricity flowed
through it which in turn would change
the way it reacted with uh with its
fluids which in turn would reorganize or
restructure the fluids what is that
process called that was discovered or
that that uh that healing modality
called that was discovered 5,000 years
ago acupuncture this is is what
acupuncture is acupuncture changes the
way elect electricity flows through the
collagen through the connective tissue
they stick needles in the connective
tissue to make the electricity more
functional so it will in turn make the
water more structured so it will in turn
reorganize the entire body you can see
all these different ways that
electricity manifests in the body and by
the way this is not the kind of
electricity that we that we tend to
think of when we turn on our light this
is electricity that is functioning at
the tiniest tiniest levels which is the
Quantum
level and it's not really electricity at
that level as much as it is
electrons which is pieces of
electricity and there's a very important
relationship between electrons which are
pieces of
electricity and um anti- electrons which
are called protons and this relationship
between electrons and protons plays a
major major role in the functioning of
the body it's like uh protons are
required to pull in
electrons protons as it turns out come
from
acid acid has a bad wrap people say oh
you're making too much acid your body's
too acidic you need to have too need to
have more alkaline but as it turns out
acid IE protons actually supports the
movement of electricity by blocking
protons you will actually stop the flow
of electricity and uh uh suppress the
actions of cells you may have heard of
something called proton pump
inhibitors Nexium and pyc these are
these are drugs that block the flow of
protons and by blocking the flow of
protons they suppress the activity
specifically in the case of nexum
product they suppress the activity of
the production of
acid so you can see electricity plays a
major major role in various places in
the body not that you necessarily have
to know how this happens except to just
be completely amazed and Blown Away by
the by how how uh tightly regulated and
orchestrated and choreographed all of
the phenomena in the body are at the
quantum level the the electron level so
how do we function how do we leverage
nutrition for all of this well the most
important uh control factor for
electronic energy in the body are the
fats fats hold on to energy they're very
rich sources of energy especially
essential fatty
acids the membrane that we talked about
that acts like a
semiconductor achieves its
semiconducting activity or functionality
through the fats it
contains fats are the most difficult
part of a food food for the body to deal
with you have to all kinds of unique
chemistry and unique uh uh organ uh
fluids in order to allow the body to
process fats from Foods bile is used for
the body to help the body process fats
from foods to a certain extent
pancreatic enzymes are involved to help
the body process fats from Foods as we
get older we don't process our fats as
effectively so one of the most important
things we could do as we get older is
make sure we're uh not only ingesting
the correct fats and that's where your
ultimate efas come in but supporting the
body's ability to get the fats out of
foods and out of from the efas into the
blood that's why digestive enzymes are
so important that's why apple cider
vinegar or betane HCL which is in the
ultimate enzy longevity are so important
and that's why of course why the
ultimate efas are so important another
very important uh electrical substance
that we should be getting in our system
all the time is something that you've
all heard the term I'm sure
electrolytes so what is an
electrolyte an electrolyte is a
molecule that dissolves in
fluid and as soon as it dissolves in
fluid it generates electrical
charges classic example of an
electrolyte is sodium chloride
actually that's two electrolytes put
together sodium and chloride if you take
sodium and if you take salt sodium
chloride is salt if you take table salt
and put in your hand there's no
electricity but as soon as you put
sodium chloride in
water the water does something really
cool it separates the sodium and the
chloride sodium chloride together they
don't do anything they're sitting in
your in your hand you're not going to
get any electricity out of that but as
soon as you put water in the sodium soon
as you put the sodium chloride in water
the water separates the
sodium and the
chloride now sodium is separate from the
chloride sodium has a positive
charge chloride has an electrical charge
what that really means is chloride has
an excess amount of electricity and
sodium has a shortage of electricity for
for whatever reason positive means a
shortage of electricity and and this is
this causes a lot of confusion for
chemistry students when they first start
learning chemistry because it turns out
when something has a positive charge it
actually means it has a shortage of
electrons and when something has a
negative charge it means it has excess
electrons and there's a reason for that
I'm not going to get into that but just
think of the chloride has a negative
charge has excess electricity the sodium
has a positive charge when they're
together there's no charge they're all
together as soon as they're separated
by water and that process of water
separating the sodium chloride is
technically called hydrolysis Hydro
means water Lis means dividing up or
breaking up or
destroying as soon as that sodium
chloride hydes in the water now you have
something very
interesting you have a positive sodium
and a negative chloride and between the
two you have an electrical charge or an
electrical conduction there's no
electricity here there's nothing that
flow they're stuck together but as soon
as they're separated you have
electricity and this is how electrolytes
work electrolytes are substances that
are solid until they're in water fluid
and then the water creates something
called charge separation this literally
it's called charge separation and now
you have flow they're separated they can
flow when they're together they can't
and this charge separation of
electrolytes is one of the ways that the
electricity in the blood and in the
fluids is
maintained as we get older and as our
blood becomes
contaminated the electrical nature of
these electrolytes of this charge SE
these charge separated electrolytes is
not as efficient the blood is doped it's
dirty and this changes the interior
blood the interior electrical energy of
the blood of the
fluids another place where uh and this
is really cool for me in the skin
business another place where uh
electricity plays a major role in the
health of the body is in the
skin the
skin generates electrical
charges from something that's very very
important in our
environment that we are terrified of I I
I did a video uh with a friend of mine a
couple days ago or a couple months ago
actually but it just got put out on Tik
Tok a couple days ago uh on the
importance of the
Sun and I talked about how sunscreens
you guys have all heard me say how
sunscreens are problematic and you want
to be out the sun oh my this always
happens I shouldn't have been surprised
oh my God the heat I got this one num
skull D dermatologist got on and she
told every how stupid I was you should
wear sunscreens because they've been
tested and and uh the sun can photo
damage you and it doesn't matter if you
have a little bit of toxicity in your
body it's okay and it was just
ridiculous we as a culture we're
terrified of the Sun but as it turns out
the sun is
streaming photonic energy
photons photons are pieces of sun
energy the sun is streaming photons that
hit the
skin when they hit the
skin there's a special element in the
body it's a nutritional element that
gets electrif that gets uh charged by
the Sun sun and this element turns the
photons into electrons it turns the
sunlight energy light into
electricity in the skin you have these
elements I'll tell you you have an
element I'll tell you what it is here in
a second that turns the sun sunlight sun
energy light energy into electrical
energy just like a solar
panel skin is like a solar panel you
know you put a solar panel on your roof
it the Sun hits the solar panel it turns
into electricity and your electrical
bill goes down and you can run your
lights and your television your
computers all from the Sun via the
action of the solar panel well our skin
does exactly that we're like so our skin
is like a solar panel and the solar
panel in the skin that converts the
photonic energy from the Sun into the
electrical energy that will charge the
body
is driven by the element
sulfur and this is the one of the key
roles of sulfur the reaction between the
Sun and sulfur creates a molecule called
sulfate and the sulfate is an
electrical is an
electrolyte that can now distribute
electrical energy through the body all
from the Sun so the next time you're out
in the sun recognize that you are now
electrifying your body and this is one
of the main places where electrical
energy comes into the body of course uh
it's not the main place where electrical
energy comes into the body because
you'll still have electrical energy even
when you're sitting in your house when
you're when you're not out in the sun
the main place we get electrical energy
is from food but where does the food get
the electrical energy from ultimately
the sun exactly so the food is like a
temporary storage space a temporary
storage device for the Electrical uh the
photonic energy that's coming from the
Sun the El uh the photonic
energy that comes from the
sun is stored in the chemicals that are
in
food it's stored specifically in a part
of the body that's or a part of the uh
the food part of the chemicals in the
food the molecules in the food called a
bond a chemical bond
and if you ever see the drawings of
chemistry if you remember your high
school chemistry you always see a line
you see C line C or or F line C or you
have all these lines those lines when
you think about it if you just you don't
really understand what's happening it
looks like there's there's a bond it's a
thing it ain't a thing it's a magnetic
interaction it's a
magnet and when you if you remember when
you're a kid and you played with magnets
how if you force two magnets together
and let go of them they would spring
apart that's because when two magnets
are pushed together they're storing
energy and as soon as you and you're
holding by holding them you're forcing
them together but as soon as you let
them go the energy is
released this is how the body gets
energy from
food all the molecules in the food are
like little magnets stuck together the
body breaks up those bonds those
connections those magnetic attractions
and Energy's released what makes the
body so amazing and really life so
amazing it has figured out how to
capture that energy if that energy when
you have a magnet you're stuck together
and the magnets fly apart the energy is
going all over the place but the
body and life itself has figured out how
to take that energy that flies around
and channel it into chemical reactions
what is it that channels the energy into
chemical
reactions the mighty 90 essential
nutrients the mighty 90 you've heard me
say this before how calories have energy
but the mighty NY essential nutrients
are what can channel the energy into the
right chemical reactions now you know
how that works the a calorie can be
thought of as two two things stuck
together and then when they get broken
apart they release energy
and if you don't have micronutrients the
energy just flies around now the body
has a way of protecting itself from all
that energy that's flying around so it
will store the energy and that's what we
call fat but if you have micronutrients
vitamin C and vitamin A and selenium and
zinc there's 90 of them they can take
that energy that has been released and
they can capture it and direct it into
the right chemical reactions and this is
how the micronutrient work this is why
the mighty 90 essential nutrients are so
important this is how this is why if
you're eating a lot of
food but you're not getting the
micronutrients which is how we eat today
we eat food but we don't get the
micronutrients most of the food we eat
doesn't have the micronutrients we get
lots of that energy just like the
magnets that you're pushing together and
then you let go we get lots of that
energy but if we don't have the
micronutrients we can't Channel that
energy into the right biochemical
reactions you follow this making sense
the micro the micronutrients are holding
on to the energy and pulling them into
the make into the chemistry that makes
collagen the te the chemistry that makes
uh uh blood or the chemistry that makes
various organel and structures and this
is why when you ingest
micronutrients you don't need as many
calories because you're more efficient
with the energy the energy is being
distributed correctly and this is is why
the micronutrients are so important so
you can see all these different places
where electricity plays a role in the
body it plays a role in the cell
membrane in the health of the cell which
acts like a little battery it and plays
a role in the in the flu in the in the
movement of blood through the body the
circulation it plays a role in the
structure of the body it plays a role uh
in the health of the uh of the connected
tissue in the collagen and it plays a
role in how we obtain energy from Foods
it plays a role in uh it play it makes
sunlight it's sun exposure important
it's why we want to be getting regular
sun exposure and most importantly it's
why we want to be eating foods that
contain the micronutrients that match up
with the macronutrients that contain the
little uh uh I heard somebody say
traffic directors the little traffic
directors for energy in addition to the
uh in addition to the raw energy
itself when we're sick we are sick at
the level of
electricity we're not sick at at the
level that we can from a fundamental
standpoint we're not sick at the level
we can see we're sick at the level of
energy we're sick at the level of
electricity the reason why nutrition is
so important is because it facilitates
the movement of
electricity and the way the system is
set up there are 90
different ways that energy can be re can
be directed into into biochemistry and
this is what the mighty 90 essential
nutrients are essentially they're ways
that the body directs the the energy
that's in food that came from the Sun
originally into the right biochemical
reactions okay so I don't know
necessarily that that's really important
to know if you're if you have cancer if
you have an autoimmune disease or if you
have Alzheimer's or you're catting
frequent colds or but it's just
interesting to see at the most
fundamental level how this whole thing
works and I believe I just scratched the
surface of the bioelectrical nature of
the body so anything we could do to to
improve the way the body handles
electricity is going to improve our
health one of the way one other thing I
should tell you
is by changing the uh the uh chemistry
of the blood you change how the blood
performs its
activity by changing the electrical
nature of the blood and one of the most
efficient and effective ways to change
the electrical nature of the blood is
with oxygen
is with breathing this is one of the
reasons why breathing is so important
why exercise is so important and why
movement is so important all this
changes the electrical nature of the
blood so oxygen is also important oxygen
contributes electrical energy as well
oxygen is also important and not as a
part of the mighty 90 essential
nutrients that you're ingesting but
through breathing through oxygenation
and it's a combination of the mighty 90
essential nutrients that are
ingested plus the calories the raw
energy that that comes in through Foods
plus oxygen that is that is breathed in
through the body plus photonic energy
from the Sun that maximizes health so
sunlight breathing and movement which
also improves oxygenation the mighty 9y
essential nutrients and a healthy diet
are the foundations of good health and
then supporting the body's ability to
utilize all that that is through the
lungs for example or through the blood
blood keeping the blood clean and also
of course through the whole digestive
processes which is where the calories
and the micronutrients are going to are
going to ultimately get into the
bloodstream through the intestine the
whole digestive
Machinery so there you go for
electricity and that's really just
scratching the surface now we're almost
I really want to leave some time for
questions because we always run out of
time but uh I'm happy to take questions
now if you have any uh if you have any
if people have questions about what I
just said or about anything else well as
I was listening I'm going back to
chemistry class and that ex I always had
that confusion with protons and being
negative and repelling and that yes I'm
I'm looking you know the the uh the
looking at the chart the chemistry chart
and all of the different chemicals and
what their abbreviations are and how
those are bonded and then water H2O
folks you got two hydrogens one oxygen
all that so for me it's kind
of I love hearing it for some it may not
be it's a little it's it can be a little
much you got to have a certain you know
like you say you have to have a certain
love for it or passion for it but it
really from at the end of the day our
customers don't care our customers
really want to just get better it's just
a a way of demonstrating how complicated
the body is how you to be very you can't
just throwing in drugs into the body and
you can't just take in things that the
body doesn't recognize this one video I
did was on sunscreens the problems with
sunscreens you can't just put things
into the body or on top of the body and
uh that the body doesn't recognize and
not to and not expect to have to pay the
price and this is why you want to be so
respectful with what you're putting in
the body and on the body you want to put
things in the body and on the body the
body has evolved to work with now the
body is very forgiving and has ability
to detoxify things but you don't want to
overload that and that's really what
we've done in the in the year 2024 we've
gone through a thousand plus
thousand by 10,000 years of changing
what gets into the body and this is what
we're we're paying the price for now and
this is why our health our health
statistics are so unbelievably crazy
where you know 60% of Americans have at
least one Health Challenge and uh 60 or
70% of Americans over the age of 65 at
least two health challenges so you know
our health the abysmal nature of our
Collective health is the end result of
our interfering with this very very
complicated Nano or Nano choreographed
biochemical nature Quantum biochemical
nature that the body has and luckily we
don't really have to do anything to work
with that the body's on automatic the
cell is on automatic all the systems in
the body are automatic as long as we
have the food the micronutrients and the
macronutrients oxygen and uh sunshine
sunl and then of course the spiritual
mental and emotional components as well
yeah so one thing that I've noticed been
because I used to go out in the sun
growing up in Phoenix I hated go out in
the sun because within five minutes I
was beat
red right now I can go out in the sun
and enjoy why is that well it's because
I've got the nutrition the
micronutrients this is this is on board
this is what this num skull doctor
didn't recognize yes the sun's a problem
because you're eating french fries and
because you're missing your
micronutrients this is why we get we
have Sun sensitivities and we have
sunburn we have photo damage is because
we're not handling the sun's energy this
is the same Sun that existed in Africa
50,000 or 100 thousand years ago when
our bodies were developing it's the same
Sun why is it all of a sudden we're all
getting sunburned and we're all getting
photo damage and everybody's is worried
about the effects of the sun is because
we're eating the wrong Foods those Foods
get stored in the skin we're our
digestive system or our intestine is
leaking toxins into the blood that gets
stored in the skin our skin becomes more
sensitive we're nutritionally deficient
using nutrients is the way we're
supposed to protect our skin from the
sun sun protection is in should be first
inside out but we don't think of it that
way we think of it as we're going to
wear shield on the outside because the
sun is evil and the Sun is going to
cause cancer and the Sun is going to uh
accelerate aging Etc and by the way when
you hear the term skin
cancer what do you think the most
important word uh the most important
word of that phrase skin cancer is it's
not skin it's cancer
skin cancer is cancer and so whether it
shows up in the skin or in the bone or
in the liver or anywhere else cancer is
a cell phenomena that's the end result
of all the same of the same thing the
only things that can go wrong with a
cell
starvation Suffocation and
toxification that's what cancer is
cancer is not an organ organ phenomena
it's a cell phenomena
all disease is cell disease and cancer
is no different so cancer is about the
cell it's not about the thyroid or the
bone or the liver or the skin or the
brain it's about the cell and it's the
end result of a cell that has been
starved and suffocated and toxified for
so long that it has now reverted into a
into for it a more effective way of of
of uh functioning so that it can get by
under conditions of in of of toxicity
and starvation and Suffocation but for
us obviously it's a problem the cell is
just trying to
survive but the end result of this cell
surviving is that it can't function as
effectively as it used to to make a
liver to make a bone or to make a brain
or to make any other of these organs
function now it turns out that the skin
is on the cell skin cells are on the
outside of the body so they're more
susceptible to excess energy from the
Sun under conditions of toxicity or or
uh starvation or Suffocation they're
going to be more sensitive but as long
as you're
healthy as long as your skin cells are
getting enough
oxygen and uh they're getting enough
nutrients and they're not toxic they're
not going to respond by becoming
carcinogenic they're not going to be
respond with cancer simply by being out
in the sun this is not something that
the medical folks recognize you know and
and consequently that's not something
that most most people recognize keep in
mind you guys listening on this on this
video or on YouTube you're at the you're
at the tip of the spear 99% of people
aren't G to pay any attention to this
they have no idea that cancer is a
cellular phenomena that the
micronutrients and and oxygenation and
detoxification can keep the body healthy
most people think oh I'm out in the sun
I better wear a sunscreen I'm going to
get photo damaged oh my mother had
diabetes so I'm going to have diabetes
or you know it's just in my family or
whatever people think about well how
they get sick nobody really realizes
that our our sicknesses and our health
problems are really mostly the result of
our lifestyle choices how we eat how we
breathe how we exercise how we move
spiritual mental and emotional of course
are involved all of that and this this
is to say that we all have an
opportunity as well as a
responsibility you know they say
information is power so now we we've
gotten some power here that most people
don't have but with power comes
responsibility and so we have an
opportunity as well as a responsibility
to help people understand that just like
their diabetes is their fault and this
is you know not to attack anybody but
it's important to understand just like
they're responsible for their diabetes
they can reverse their diabetes just
like they're responsible for their
autoimmunity they can reverse their
autoimmunity just like they're
responsible for their neurological or
movement disorders or or mental health
health challenges or dementias or
whatever it is they can reverse that as
well and so we have a responsibility we
really owe it to people to say that as
we understand this we owe it to people
we owe it to others to teach uh what
we've learned and we also have an
opportunity to help people to make a
difference and this is one of the best
things about youngevity probably the
best thing about youngevity is it gives
us an opportunity to make a difference
in the world people who who I've met in
youngevity are all people who want to
make a difference who want to make the
world a better place and youngevity is
our platform for doing that it's our
vehicle for doing that not not just with
the products but also with information
and not just with information but maybe
even most importantly with
inspiration we can inspire people
because people are so lost and they're
so frustrated and they don't know where
to turn and I I feel that way probably
many if not most of if not all of you
guys feel that way too we don't know
where to turn we don't know what to do
we don't know where to go there are
people out there supplementing because
they heard their mother say something or
their friends say something or their
neighbors say something or they read
something on the Internet and they
they're taking this and they're taking
that and they don't know what to do and
they don't know what companies to go to
we've got systems we've got kits we've
got it all set up for people got
diabetes got a blood sugar pack you've
got heart disease you got a heart pack
you got a a joint problems you got a
bone pack we not only have products but
we also have education we got
information to me this is the most
powerful and important business
opportunity company business opportunity
compan that anybody can ever interact
with when it comes to health and there's
nothing more fundamental than health so
we have a responsibility and we have an
opportunity because while you know
there's 30 people in this call 50 people
100 people there's millions of people
that have no idea about the
possibilities that are uh that they have
to not only eliminate health challenges
but even if they don't have a Health
Challenge just to improve their quality
of life and to increase their
longevity and I grateful that I found it
because eight years
ago eight years ago there's there's no
way I would have ever dreamed to be able
to do this or be outside and play and
take care of others because I couldn't
take care of myself I was in such poor
health let me let me say one last thing
let me just say one last thing one of
the things electricity in the blood does
as I was kind of alluding to is it
improves the movement of the blood and
one of the ways to improves the movement
of the blood is by spreading the blood
cells
apart when you spread the blood cells
apart everything moves moves more
efficiently when you have doping of the
blood when you have toxicity in the
blood everything clumps up that's why
blood clotting is such a is the major
side effect of injecting you know what
through your blood when you inject you
know what through your blood I can't say
what it is because for YouTube but when
you inject you know what through your
blood it dopes the blood everything
contaminates everything uh the blood
becomes contaminated and everything
clumps up that's where clotting comes
from oxygen by the way is one of the
best way one of the best ways to spread
things out oxygen uh creates an
electrical milu that separates out blood
cells and that's why breathing is one of
the most important things you could do
if you have heart disease or if you have
blood disease or you're worried about a
stroke or you have a history of blood
clots well we have a product that one is
one of the most
incredible red blood cell spreaders
apart now one one I should tell you one
of the one of the uh the blood
cells Clump up when there there's not
enough negative charges in the blood
negative charges remember have or excess
electricity so negative charges help the
blood spread apart oxygen breathing
oxygen improves the negative charges in
the uh in the blood and helps spread up
our blood cells so do essential fatty
acids which also act as a source of
electrical energy that can help spr
spread blood cells apart and it turns
out that uh the ultimate efas are a
great blood thinner in fact there's such
a great blood thinner sometimes doctors
will say not to use the ultimate efas
right but one of my favorite blood
thinners are the negative charges that
come from we said sulfur has negative
charges come from the sun right well
there are these creatures that live in
the Sun and they're very tiny little
creatures that live out in the sun and
they live in
this vast
expanse of fluids that have an ability
to pull the sun's energy in and in fact
they're at the bridge they're are at the
at the interface of the Sun and this
fluid and they have an ability to take
the photonic energy and trap it in uh in
Sulfur just like our skin does and
create these sulfate
molecules these creatures that trap the
sun sun's energy in Sulfur like our skin
does like I
described are called
algaes and collectively the algae Bunch
up to form
seaweeds there's a special kind of
seaweed that is very very rich in these
sulfur molecules these sulfate
molecules it's a brown seed seaweed and
this brown seaweed contains molecules
that uh have trapped the sun's energy
that we can eat and then get the sun's
energy and uh the electrical energy that
has been converted from the sun which
will go into the blood and spread those
blood cells apart and makes this one
algae one of the best blood thinning
ingredients you could ever have so for
folks who have have gotten the injection
and they're concerned about clots or if
they have a history of blood clots or if
they have any kind of uh circulatory
health issues or any kind of health
issue they will benefit by ingesting the
fucoid Z which is fucoidin
sulfate the fucoidin contains lots of
sulfate which it got which It produced
by the photonic energy from the Sun in
response to the photonic energy in the
sun they store electrical energy in
Sulfur to create sulfate we can eat that
when we eat our fucoid Z and it will
help thin the blood and it's one of the
reasons why the fucoid Z is is so
multi-functional and it's one of the
reasons why I consider the fucoid Z to
be aside from the mighty non essential
nutrients and uh and in the healthy Star
Pack the basics I can it's my favorite
uh one of my favorite youngevity
products I have a few favorites it's one
of my favorite y I love that one too I
do I do I've got so many great um
testimonials come in over the last week
from being from adding that after having
Raymond and Yolanda Brown on the show
with where we were talking about
fucoidin and then you did a followup
that spoke about the fucoidin right and
get people on that and and for some
people that's like the missing link yeah
to helping get over that I mean they're
feeling better they still had those few
things that were just holding on and
adding in one or both the fiden or the
zradical into their programs has just
made a world of differ so I I love it um
I take both every day myself uh and I
just I can't say enough good things
about it besides the fact that you know
Z radical tastes good fuc covid and Z
you take it through pills you get even
more without having any of the the
sugars if you're concerned about sugars
so it's I love how
youngevity meets people where they're at
yeah
I agree everybody needs the
90 and then we each have these areas
that the cells have become weakened
because of the lack of nutrition the
lack of oxygen as you were mentioning
the starvation the Suffocation it's
just we don't have to be that way right
we really don't and it's best if we
start
early so that we don't have to feel that
way but even if we've gone to the point
where we're feeling all these poor
health symptoms we can still do
something because we're empowered to
make a
difference so I love it I love it um and
I know Phyllis has a question she wanted
to make sure that we get in today so
okay so let's take one question from
Phyllis get Phyllis in nice to see you
Phyllis nice to see you Ben I love this
topic it's just mind right oh my
goodness yes uh Sharon had an a question
regarding
Resveratrol yes and Ms um people with Ms
yes and uh there was um she was
concerned about it and I did some
research there was what do you mean she
yeah what was she concerned about
exactly a study came out I learned um
involving mice in
2013 yes and uh they gave mice res
veratrol yes and their conclusion was
with the people with m Ms were actually
being warned not to take Resveratrol
supplements uh after this study found
that it worsened Ms like neur
neuropathology and inflammation and had
no
neuroprotective effects so she's
concerned about taking Resveratrol and
she has a m a she or someone she knows
okay well to be concerned about res
veritol when you have M first of all
that's not I that that makes no sense at
all and would have to see that to see
how that happened but but the thing is
to worry about
Resveratrol when you have multiple
sclerosis is like worried about a little
mosquito floating around your head when
you have a big elephant on your
roof you know you got way bigger fish to
fry than worrying about res Vera and as
you know I'm gonna assume this person
hasn't heard us talk before I I always
hate to repeat myself but you know
there's always new people so Ms is an
autoimmune
disease autoimmunity should always be
regarded first and for foremost as a
sign of dirty
blood and I gave the mechanism I don't
want to you know bore anybody by
repeating the mechanism but basically
toxicity gets into the blood through the
intestine the immune system is then
activated with h toxicity gets into the
bloodstream through the intestine the
blood immune system is activated the
blood being the Sacred Space uh the
immune Sy the blood will then dump all
that toxicity that's in the blood into
various tissues including the nerves and
then immune system then attacks the
nerves which it now perceives as being
distorted from the toxicity stop eating
and you'll notice your MS symptoms start
to disappear it's so tragic to me how
people have MS and they deal with the
medical model which will tell you they
they admit you know doctors are are
honest about it they don't they don't
lie they say we can't do anything so
just give you steroids you know because
they can't really do anything but if you
read the walls protocol Dr Terry walls
Wahls everybody with Ms or everybody
with any autoimmune disease should read
this uh she was a medical doctor she is
a medical doctor and she had Ms she
cured herself yes she cured herself of
Ms okay how did she do that she changed
the way she
ate that's it she's a medical doctor she
wrote a whole book on it the walls
protocol everybody that M should read it
but you know if you heard me speak for
the last 20 years you know exactly how
it happens you don't need to read the
book but it's good to read the book
because she's a medical doctor you know
she's mainstream uh she's not you know
an alternative practitioner she's not a
chir fractor or or a naturopath she's a
standard medical doctor and she said you
know change the way you eat happened to
be with her it was it was gluten but it
could be anything you don't want to just
focus on gluten just focus on intestinal
health so I want I'd like to talk to
somebody who has Ms because I wanted
them to get on here and we can talk
about their digestive situation I've yet
to I've worked with a lot of Ms patients
I've yet to see an MS patient that did
not have long-standing intestinal
problems I've never seen that I've
worked with a lot of Ms Pat but if you
understand the mechanism it just makes
perfect sense so ratr is a you know
Resveratrol has some some effects some
powerful effects but you need a lot of
it it's very expensive most RIS veratrol
containing products have a drop of RIS
veratrol in them uh so you're really not
going to it's very difficult to get uh
RIS veratrol effects just from RIS
veratrol supplements there are sources
there's food sources of Resveratrol
mostly berries peanuts have some
Resveratrol in them
um grapes have ratol of course most
people know that um so there's lots of
ways you can get ratol from food and
that's probably a good idea to do it uh
but it's not like RIS veritol is ever
going to change your life uh it is
anti-inflammatory and in conjunction
with a lot of other things you might get
some benefits from it as far as making
inflammation worse that's got to be a
misunderstanding of some kind of study I
can't I've never heard of anything like
that but even if it was the case like I
say if you have a gnat or a mosquito
around your head uh and you have an
elephant on your roof you got bigger
problems than the mosquito or the N
perfect I'll let her know thanks it's so
simple such a simple answer yeah it
really is and that is you know as as
complicated as it gets and we you know
we talk about the electricity there's
all this complication here it's a real
Simplicity to health because the body's
on automatic it the cells know what to
do I mean when you think about it a cell
is microscopic right I mean we get we
say this all the time it's important
that we like really let it percolate in
our brains you have an entity that is so
tiny you can't see it it's
invisible if that alone should give us
pause you have a how can you imagine
this this entity is so small if I had it
right in front of me I couldn't see it
because it's so tiny but yet this entity
that is so tiny somehow can produce
hundreds of different chemicals on its
own how a factory that a human being
makes can't do that how does an entity
that's microscopically small have the
intelligence to know which of hundreds
of different chemical chical to make a
liver cell a hpy can make 500 different
chemicals how does it know which chemal
to make which chemical to make how much
to make of it and when to make it it's
microscopically small where does it get
the information to do that this is just
mind-blowing yet we don't have to know
any of that stuff all we got to do is
make sure we give the raw materials we
go out and get electricity from the Sun
you know all the things we just talked
about and that's really the beauty of it
but you can go as deep as you want uh if
you want to go deep you can go you know
you can go all the way into the
microscopic nature of the body and and
you know when we talk about electricity
in the body really this is very
important you know a bolt of lightning a
vol first of all a volt or voltage
refers to the push when something has a
positive voltage it's the electric being
pushed when it has negative voltage it's
being sucked so positive voltage is push
lightning is a classic example of
something that has a lot of voltage
lightning is a reaction between positive
charges is a negative charge that whole
charge separation thing we talked about
that manifest in the atmosphere is
lightning you got negative on the bottom
you got positive on the top this the
clouds are and up in the air are are
positive charges the ground is negative
charges when there's enough positive
charges and enough negative charges you
get a bolt of lightning a bolt of
lightning has uh a
billion a billion
volts a cell also has voltage it also
has energy it's also pushing El
electricity a cell has about 07 volts of
energy in a Cell but you have about 100
trillion cells if you multiply 07 volts
in a single
cell by 100 trillion
cells that's a lot of energy that's
seven trillion
volts that's
7,000 bolts of lightning in a body
what is this this is so amazing right
you have the equivalent in electrical
energy of thousands of bolts of
lightning and this is what we're riding
around in we as whatever we are inside
this body we're riding around this
amazing system of organization and and
intricacy and precision that is so exact
that we can only just worship it and be
blown away by it we can't really you
know we all we got to do is we don't we
can't run it all we got to do is feed it
and breathe it and move it and that's it
and we can't even do that
right all right you guys it's already
late thank you we any other question
well I know that um Dr wallet just wants
to get on and what you are saying as
well so doc Dr
Wall hello hello hey
Doc yes thank you really a great great
great presentation thank you so much
thank you I appreciate
that so doc you've gone deep into the
body and how everything works do you
agree with what pharmacist Ben just said
oh absolutely and of course when it
comes to um the brain and spinal cord
and the big nerves like the tenth
cranial nerve um it's it's one of those
Miracles that God made when you think
about it allthough there is things that
they do
um and uh just demonization when you
don't get enough raw materials to make
milin the um milin sheath goes away from
the brain cells and spinal core cells
and you get let's see here you get um
well there's a lot you can get Dr wall
so I was hoping we could just make this
quick because we are on overtime
pharmacist Ben has to get to his next
yeah appointment but just give me two
minutes because the want to say we get
990,000 in America we get 90,000 new
cases of Parkinson disease each year got
90,000 that's the new statistics came
out by the government 90,000 new cases
of Parkinson's disease each year in
America which is a simple nutritional
deficiency disease which results in
milein deficiency Alzheimer disease
Parkinson disease MS multiple sclerosis
amyotropic glos sclerosis ALS
Huntington's Korea frontal temporal
dementia which is kind of like an
Alzheimer Seas it just affects the front
of the brain and temples and 990,000 new
cases each year in America because
people are just eating
wrong so if they change the way they eat
and stop putting in the toxins and
creating dirty blood and you add in the
90 essential nutrients plus the things
that really help allow the digestive
system to work properly keep the blood
clean yeah as empowered individuals we
can do a lot for ourselves right yeah
well we can stop and we'll go from
90,000 new cases of Parkin Z each year
to zero we can do that in three to six
months okay I think that's fantastic Dr
wallik I think that's absolutely
fantastic I can't thank F has been
enough for everything he did to just
really a great great thing thank you doc
that means a lot to me doc thank you for
everything thank you enough for all the
great stuff you do for Humanity thank
you so much for being on our side thank
you thank you doc thank you Becca thank
you Ben and I want to just do a thank
you to my team as well as they help us
put this all together pharmacist bin you
were on fire fantas we appreciate you
and you know we didn't have time for
questions but we will get except for for
the one we will get more time with next
week let's do all questions we'll do all
questions that was going to be my
suggestion so okay good thank you thank
you thank you pharmacist Ben F folks you
want to make sure that you catch all of
our pharmacist Fridays and then we also
have past shows called Q&A with
pharmacist Ben and Becca that you can
find on our YouTube
channel under critical Health news or
just do a search for Q&A with pharmacist
Ben and Becca those will come up as well
but I know you need to get going so I'm
gonna go ahead and let you do what you
need to do as he continues to help
others and does presentations for others
as well we just really respect and
appreciate the time that he dedicates to
us folks us not just critical Health
news not just daily with duck doc but us
as in you
too so as somebody that has greatly
benefited from the information that I
share on this program the people that I
bring in as guests whether they're
consistent guests like Dr wallic and
once a week which we're hoping to get
them more than once a week with
pharmacist Ben fukes but others as well
who are experts in the field of
nutrition who have found that youngevity
is the way to go youngevity has put
together the solutions under Dr Wall's
guidance that really do impact and make
a difference within the human body we
invite you to fill it as well get back
with the person that shared this program
with you if there is no one to thank
give our call team a call
3377 again that's 855
3377 and you will get in contact with
one of our certified holistic health
coaches you can also go to our website
and use that contact option or as you're
filling out the request to be put on our
email list there's a spot that you can
submit your health questions include in
there if you're working with somebody or
if you want to be connected with a coach
from our team if you're already working
with somebody you belong with them they
made the effort they shared information
that grabbed your attention we want to
make sure that you stay with them as
well I couldn't do this without my team
the people that I have on with us which
Phyllis had to go a little bit early you
saw her as she brought in a question
from the
audience um she's been with Dr Wall
probably the longest of anyone that I
personally know beyond Cheryl Morley she
and and uh sh Murphy which for those of
you who are Dead Doctors Don't Lie you
remember sha she's still going and
kicking but Phyllis and her husband Andy
were very instrumental in getting that
Dead Doctors Don't Lie program
syndicated around on the different radio
stations along with MZ Michael zerling
who we want to do a thank you so much um
to MZ and all that he's done to help
make this program possible as well now
with us we have Marilyn Marilyn is doing
a fantastic job as she is doing
dictation putting it into the chat so if
you are just watching this as a replay
or watching the live stream you don't
see the chat there's a lot of great
information we invite you to come and
join us live as we do our live daily
with docs just simple super super simple
daily with Doc
zoom.com um 12 to 1ish p.m. Pacific Time
right now we're Wednesday Thursday
Friday working on more days as well so
daily withth do zoom.com Marilyn does a
fantastic job as she's putting in with
her Speedy fingers Yes Albert um
information into the chat we have Albert
who is coming from us it's in the middle
of the night folks but he believes in
this message so much and has just
benefited from it and also those that he
has shared with it have benefited from
the message that he's here with us
helping to make sure that we create a
safe place for all so thank you so much
Albert as he's joining us from South
Africa fols we don't have any borders
when it comes to people needing
nutrition we want to provide it provide
the opportunity for people to be able to
get what their bodies need that includes
you no matter where you're at get back
with the person that share this program
with you and then I have with us uh AJ
AJ has been very instrumental in getting
our program out onto the various
platforms so that you can find it at any
time
247 even if you are on Apple TV Roku TV
Fire tv YouTube Rumble Spotify um Amazon
music I mean we are everywhere and they
just put up a list here for me but I
didn't uh didn't go through the list but
I do want to welcome back our YouTube
viewers as we have a lot of people that
watch us on YouTube and interact in that
chat welcome back as we are
um loving the fact that yeah they want
to protect people from misinformation
but folks the
misinformation um that we provide
actually helps people so you can't deny
that one my name is Becca dukes and as
the hostess of this program I thank you
for taking the time and investing the
time into yourself and we invite you to
feel the difference by investing in what
you actually put into your body and what
we have found to be synergistic
solutions that the body can actually use
so give youngevity a try visit our web
ite daily withth do.com we have a full
store there we also have the Good Foods
bad foods list and if you're already
working with somebody get back with them
until next time bye for
[Music]
now
pap
[Music]
la
a
[Music]
la
n
[Music]
p
o
[Music]
n